has come for us my name is fit ha and
welcome to furnish me
today we're going to do this selfie
challenge where I am challenging you
pros on Instagram to post me a selfie
and I will copy the selfie or probably
do it better than you do it because I am
just superior senpai you should just be
glad that I even noticed you no problem
why is he not taking the picture how was
that yes let's go with a crema filter a
victory to the pose what am I supposed
to copy here oh my gosh yes saved
another victory yes I know I need to
charge my iPad thank you oh my god how
do you do that with a nose I could never
do that my nose is too wide I can't do
it I can't do it
close enough crime on that [ __ ] now
here's a great one I am best friends
with my leg selfie it's time for me to
show off my agility now that's what I'm
talking about when I talk about legs oh
look it's edgers turn to reply what I'll
[ __ ] write that [ __ ] again
oh yeah oh my god you smell look over
here you [ __ ]
oh my god the struggles ha ha yeah
another victor taking this naked what
the [ __ ] is this think mine is a lot
superior oh Jesus Christ
alright finally a worthy opponent
alright let's see how close we can go
yeah okay this one is gonna be difficult
but I'm gonna give it a try
another Victor what even is this I'm
taking my pans out for this one
how did you get the leg up there I don't
understand that's some sexy [ __ ] yes
it's on my underwear oh boy oh boy
wasn't that a good time I have a lot of
fun wrecking your brother's head selfies
it's a shame you're not good enough but
really you tried that's all for me for
now see you next Friday or next video
rather it's a breakfast for you stay
awesome bros oh [ __ ] look at this and
t-shirts I used to have beauty it's
obvious that was that was probably the
first running joke out of my channel
because I didn't edit my videos back
then and I keep kept getting stuck and I
wouldn't edit out parts where I got
stuck and everyone would just be like oh
my god